Dr. Zakia, is there any information that
you need to impart to the viewers of
Peace TV before we start this long
series of interviews and question and
answer sessions regarding Ramadan, a
date with Dr. Zakir. Alhamdulillah.
Before we start this long series of
episodes Ramadan Dr. Zakir I would like
to make my position very clear that I
consider myself to be a student of
knowledge. I consider myself to be a
Talib. I don't consider that I'm a
scholar to give fatwas as far as Islamic
ruling is concerned. And as far as this
topic on Ramadan, there are various
issues and there are various difference
of opinions as far as different scholars
are concerned as far as different
schools of thought are concerned. Since
there are only four verses in the Quran
dealing directly with Ramadan that's
surah bakar chapter 2 verse number 183,
verse number 184, verse number 185 and
verse number 187. There are indirectly
another few verses but directly only
four verses. So most of the rulings are
based on the hadith and some scholars
have used zad, some have used mud
hadith, some have used say hadith. So as
far as what I'll be answering it will
basically be the views of different
scholars only I'll be selecting those
scholars who I feel have quoted on the
bas of Quran and say hadith. So it may
not agree with some of the viewers view
which they used to. Our opinion should
always be based on Quran and say hadith
when required I may give the difference
of opinion different scholars. I'll name
the scholars if required. Most of the
times I may not name but I would like to
make it very clear at the outset that
all the answers as far as Ramadan issues
are concerned none of them are my own
answers. there are basically some or the
other scholars who have said it and I'll
try my level best to name the scholars
whenever required so that no one feels
that I'm trying to give my own opinion
but I always believe that the answer
should be based on Quran and say hadith
so that I'll try my level best and
inshallah as far as possible whenever I
quote a hadith I will try and give the
references whether some say bkari or say
Muslim the volume number as well as
hadith number so that people can you
know check it up and as far as possible
I'll be quoting will be authentic and
similarly with the of the Quran and
that's my normal method of giving
replies so that people whenever they get
the answer they get from authentic Quran
and say hadith and whatever right or
good that comes out from my mouth will
be from Allah subhanana wa ta'ala and
whatever wrong and mistakes that come
from my mouth will be from my side and
from the side of the shaitan. So I seek
refuge with Allah from sitting in the
curse and I pray to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala that may this series be
beneficial for all of us including the
viewers in a